blah blah blah you guys are always
saying these are too long gutter space
the only pop culture news show where the
host sounds completely intoxicated no
matter how sober he is
remember when they said this would be a
prequel to mcu spider-man set the time
before he was recruited by iron man that
idea sounded awful because no
significant or interesting story could
happen in that time span without fully
contradicting the movies well guess what
the whole show is about contradicting
the movies
this show is under the mcu brand but is
not canon to any of the movies and is
just its own divergent timeline where
norman osborne recruits peter to mentor
him instead of tony stark i already love
that idea osborne would totally see this
gifted kid and think wow he's a genius
and a living weapon look at little
goblin junior gotta exploit that for
nefarious deeds
most of his early comic appearances have
him going like harry sucks you'd make a
better son peter
so this is a fine change and it'll be
cool to see that relationship decay when
peter realizes the kind of guy norman is
and finally challenges him as spider-man
near the end of the season plus he won't
just be wearing a lame prototype suit
for the whole show he's got the classic
duds and a bunch of
uh costumes from the identity crisis arc
that's cool scorpion and doc ock will be
there and so will daredevil voiced by
charlie
[Music]
all this stuff has me hyped hearing that
this is in its own continuity that can
do whatever they want with the character
is the best news we've had so far
because you know i'm kind of
a little burned out on the mcu being
pushed forward as the default everything
now yeah looking at mcu spider-man and
going alright but what if we attempted
to actually you know make it more like
the comics is frankly hilarious of a
direction but i'm interested to see how
they pull it off it's been a while since
we've had a spider-man cartoon ultimate
spider-man ended and then there was
nothing for like eight years nothing at
all just gotta wait another two years oh
jesus
maybe because of this and spectacular
spidey being added to netflix i should
consider revisiting a certain series of
videos in the meantime
daredevil season 4 announced except they
titled it after the storyline they
already adapted for some reason it'll be
18 episodes long instead of six so
hopefully it'll be an actual tv show
instead of a six hour movie chopped into
segments with terrible pacing
that that obi-wan [ __ ] was embarrassing
that could have absolutely been a movie
x-men 97 has shown more character
designs and details some of the
occasional guest members of the team
from the original series are joining the
x-men in a more long-term manner for the
new season and they're adapting that
stuff where magneto is leading the team
because professor x was dedified and he
felt bad about being such a jerk to him
all the time i think the spot where the
original series left off actually leads
into this pretty well and it makes sense
for the characters to go that route at
this point they have storm's mohawk yes
i'm glad at least one x-men thing isn't
being hilariously mismarveled i i mean
mismanaged what if
captain carter was interesting
what if
the show was good i don't care about
what if season two i'm not gonna watch
it the first one was lame and bad and
the voice acting is terrible except for
the characters that are voiced by actual
voice actors instead of their live
action actors and the concepts are
really lame like oh what if this
character was switched with this
character oh okay they suck this is a
news show but it's also heavily
opinionated we've been over this i'm
reporting the thing but also what i
think about it you otherwise you could
just go read the article [ __ ] off marvel
zombies will also be super mcu inspired
unfortunately but at least it'll be tvma
so even if it's terrible maybe it'll
have some fun gore and zombie designs
[Applause]
one of the first comics i ever read was
robert kirkman's marvel zombies which is
absolutely an appropriate book for a
seven-year-old and that book is near and
dear to my heart so naturally i'm also
pretty cynical about this you veered so
far off the book and the only thing you
adapted one for one was t'challa being
hacked up for meat supply on a medical
table
that's [ __ ] up bro why is t'challa
getting jacked and what if so much
speaking of t'challa getting jacked he
has officially died off screen and
wakanda forever is all about side
characters uniting together to find a
new black panther kind of like that
batman battle for the cowl thing the
trailer is actually pretty hype but i'm
worried that the decision to kill him
off instead of recasting will cause
t'challa to be ditched in everything for
mcu synergy
you know like the rumored ea game where
you're apparently playing as a new black
panther after the original has died
plus the comics look to be edging him
out too and that's
not okay
like at all let's honor bozeman by just
throwing away his character in every
medium simultaneously come on t'challa's
cool keep him around please
ant-man 3 apparently starts with ant-man
acting completely out of character and
they recast cassie lang for uh seemingly
no reason on record so that's a yikes
already
hopefully kang the conquerment is cool
in it though it's kind of nice that
something is going to actually
acknowledge the loki show existed
i figured the timeline splintering into
a billion branch universes would have
been a bigger deal and it would have
tied into the other three multiverse
projects recently but i guess not
these movies are feeling more and more
disconnected and disparate in really
weird ways
everyone's talking about the
disappearing for five years thing but
the giant bird skeleton fighting an
alligator in egypt the sky changing back
to thousands of years ago
a monster as big as a planet appearing
in orbit and uh giant corpse poking out
of the ocean
are all just getting glossed over i mean
spider-man's shenanigans tearing a
massive hole in the atmosphere like that
futurama movie gets a pass because
you know memory erasing magic but maybe
everyone in this world has become just
strangely desensitized to crazy
life-altering terrifying [ __ ] that's
happening outside of the control of
normal people
it's okay now because it's easier to
skip several of these movies and shows
at a shot without wondering what's
happening like
the thing that made the mcu cool and
exciting eight years ago has become such
a detriment now that i'm glad they're
doing less and less of it and i have far
less boring content to watch
mcu phases are accelerating in speed so
the next one is gonna be like a damn
year long but have a billion projects in
it including ones not even listed on
this schedule at the thing and i'm
getting really tired but kevin's plan to
keep me hooked was just to make
daredevil the [ __ ] main character of
the universe and have him in five new
things at once uh so
i guess i have to watch those
there's two avengers movies coming out
in the year 2025 and that'd be a great
time for vfx artists to officially
unionize and just cause all kinds of
chaos
you know considering all the news coming
out about the marvel vfx sweatshops and
their workers putting in 70 hours a week
or sleeping at their desks now is a
great time to put their foot down
because things are about to get a lot
worse for them if they don't dc showed
black atom and shazam stuff it's weird
how those two are at the forefront of
their current movie lineup and still
have no real confirmation that they'll
be crossing over soon but it seems
pretty certain that it's coming both of
these look pretty neat but i like the
costumes in the first shazam a little
more
they aren't talking about flash they
aren't showing flash trailers they have
nothing to say about the flash that
movie is going to get unceremoniously
dumped on hbo max probably with no
advertising so they can just wash their
hands of the whole
weird scary situation in fact it's
gotten bad enough that the plan to
completely replace ben affleck's batman
with time travel retcon michael keaton
is now in question and affleck's batman
is replacing keaton's and aquaman too
all right that's cool if he's down for
it i guess i don't know i like ben
affleck batman like a little i you know
his writing was not always stellar but i
you could tell
he was trying his best
and uh
his costumes were the best ones new
transformers cartoon
[Music]
i don't know how to do this i just i
just wrote this with like a hundred o's
and i don't know why i haven't been too
jazzed on transformers cartoons since
prime ended actually take it from my
good friend the black transformer jazz
what's cracking my homies jazz gets down
with the wrong music i'm like robots in
disguise uh the other newer show titled
that not the old one wasn't really
keeping me interested and i didn't like
the art style and then cyberverse was
like the same problem but a different
flavor the netflix trilogy was really
joyless and dry and ruined beast wars
and was just
hard to sit through
voice acting was bad because everyone
was trying to sound serious all the time
like i am optimus prime and this war has
ravaged my world
and i am
and this war
must be waged prime
and i'm starscream and i also talk at a
really low whisper all the time like
this and i'm bumblebee
and i'm supposed to be the fun one but i
also talk like this and this isn't my
war
i don't want to be involved in your war
bumblebee you have to join our war
prime this war
that's the whole [ __ ] show it's the
worst i'm hoping this is the one that
really gets my attention again for the
franchise and characters alan tudyk's
optimus prime is kind of an inspired
choice and i thought he sounded all
right in this trailer it's interesting
to see him take on voicing a more
serious character because typically he's
assigned to funny guys or serial killers
or whatever and this will be a
refreshing take and danny pooty is
bumblebee is sick too i just get excited
by the words bumblebee voiced by blank
because oh thank god he can finally
speak again but you know he seems like a
good choice too i'm interested i hope
this one's good i'm going into it with
an open mind i'm primarily optimistic
warner brothers has apparently entered
panic mode again after uh coming down
from smoking too much crack and uh now
they're reshuffling their dc movie slate
for the hundredth time likely because
the flash movie was the hinge of their
entire reboot for the brand and that's a
whole weird situation now this has
resulted in them just
just canceling the batgirl movie that
was coming hbo max even though it was
already done they shot the whole thing
even did the reshoots it was edited
together and it was done
the wb just decided they don't want to
do it now so it's canceled they won't be
in theaters or on hbo max it's just
gone their publicly stated reason being
that they want to start focusing on big
theatrical blockbuster event movies and
batgirl was apparently too
grounded in small scale for that i guess
oh man we were gonna see brendan
fraser's firefly that would have been
cool jk simmons was gordon again and
michael keaton would be batman because
of time travel but
i i don't know i feel like they don't
want to put it out because it's so
reliant on the flash movie for
continuity and that one isn't a weird
state of flux currently so this is
especially like what do we do with it
and since it only cost 90 million
dollars to make they consider it an
acceptable loss which is like [ __ ] up
they're also doing the same thing to the
scoob sequel that as far as i know was
also done or near completed
damn even though mutants came out
eventually when was the last time an
entire completed movie was just
obliterated after it was done uh
probably that weird black and white
louis ck movie about like how he thinks
woody allen is like a weirdo but then
louis ck was also being a weirdo so no
one would distribute it batgirl and
scuba in some odd company i really hope
they back off of this decision and just
release it on streaming at the very
least for the people who worked on it
and so we can see what it was like um
how can we save this movie oh i know
nuclear option
hey you bloodthirsty snyder cut kids if
you're pro director freedom and
anti-warner brothers being shitty to
people who work for them
aim some of that unbridled murderous
rage at this situation because well this
is completely unfair to everyone who
worked on the movie they spent years of
their lives on this thing it should at
least come out lord knows you guys have
the resources to make wb cry and [ __ ]
their pants in front of everyone time
and again so tell them to release
batgirl
but you know like nicely like
as nice as you people can and and god
help the poor bastard who tries to
cancel blue beetle because his costume
is perfect and i want to see my boy
jaime in live action damn dc why you
gotta break my heart i like i like comic
book movies i mean i don't like them
that much i'm like fascinated
about talking about them honestly all of
the movies i've liked this year are like
barely comic book related oh except
batman batman was cool hey you guys seen
nope that was cool
what other movies came out there oh yeah
that nicholas cage movie where he plays
himself that was cool
type in the comments what your favorite
movie was this year that was not related
to comic books in any way shape or form
i feel like we're getting to a point
where we forget those exist as a society
a little bit and we need to work on that
oh my god
it's lady gaga lady gaga is apparently
for sure playing harley quinn in the
joker too
i
had to announce something to get people
off their backs about batgirl
this was not it totally didn't work
in addition to that warner brothers are
merging the service with discovery
getting rid of a lot of their animated
projects they cancelled the supergirl
movie cancelled that strange tales show
with kevin smith the new ceo says he
hates scripted television
rumored to be removing many of their
original streaming content which has no
physical release so it'll become lost
media that can only be viewed through
piracy potentially cancel the
live-action green lantern series and
killing all the puppies in chicago
in brighter news beavis and butthead is
somehow still funny after 25 years off
the air minus a brief return in 2011 and
the new season has somehow translated
them to the modern era perfectly rise of
the tmnt went out with a really
spectacular bang and the movie is
absolutely worth checking out for its
incredible visuals and action scenes as
well as its really heartfelt story i
borrowed my wife's sister's netflix to
watch it because i cancelled mine months
ago out of spite for all the good shows
killed too soon like so many chicagoan
puppies and praised the best predator
movie since the original and has really
reinvigorated the franchise after that
terrible 2018 movie nearly killed it i
recommend checking out prey in the tms
that was a good day august 5th good day
rosario dawson may have accidentally
goofed and announced that the punisher
is coming back for another season but i
found out yesterday that the punisher
was happening again so i feel like it's
my second chance because it was the only
one of the shows that i wasn't in and i
love john bernthal
if that's true then hopefully he
actually does punish her stuff in this
one instead of quitting and trying to
live a normal life for the third god
damn time if you want to support the
show hit up our patreon where you can
see videos a couple days early sometimes
sometimes only a few hours early because
i get a little stupid lazy um and you
can see exclusive behind the scenes
videos and extra special stuff that's
only for the patrons
um and then also you can go buy a bunch
of random toys and junk from me on my
ebay over here
uh because i have way too many toys and
and like collectibles and [ __ ] so if you
want to buy some of those you can uh you
could buy merch we have merch i haven't
talked about the merch in like over a
year and a half but we do have merch i'm
sure ben will make some of this
salvageable ben please
please do your magic little buddy that's
why he calls me the magic man i asked
him not to call me that but he insists
are you reading funyuns back there
you dropped it on the floor i don't want
that one
okay fine i'm gonna eat the floor funyun
ready
[Music]
you